[Musique]
vitrail brisé troncs des dossiers à
l'aide d'une disqueuse
tabernacle profané fracturée et vidé de
son contenu lieu le plus sacré de
l'église parce qu'on y entrepose là les
hosties consacrées pour nous les
catholiques c'est le corps du christ
donc tout a été vidée mais s'étaient
efforcés
tout ce qu'il y avait dedans des
centaines d'os tic qui ont été volés
tout et tout est parti c'est triste soit
c'est de l'ignorance soit c'est de la
méchanceté pour atteindre quelque chose
qui est précieux pour certains et quelle
sacrée on touche au coeur coire et du
désarroi et surtout une perte estimée
entre 10000 et 12000 euros le père petit
fils en appelle aux autorités locales
c'est important qu'on soit pas livré à
nous-mêmes dans ces conditions la wii
donc ce serait un bien que les un
représentant du public soient à nos
côtés aussi pour défendre la liberté de
culte corps aussi enfin c'est un peu ça
un soutien politique plus que nécessaire
pour l'église depuis janvier 2021 686
actes antichrétiens ont eu lieu en
france le préfet de seine-saint-denis
est conscient de l'urgence c'est tout
l'objet de la mission qui a été confiée
aux gouvernements aux des deux députés
compte accompagner nos intérieurs qui
m'ont accompagné tout à l'heure ici de
justement de fonder des propositions
pour voir comment on peut mieux prendre
en compte la sécurité passive et active
de ces lieux à quelques kilomètres de
bondy des faits similaires se sont
produits dans la paroisse de saint
germain l'auxerrois a romainville le
procédé identique laisse penser que ce
sont les mêmes individus qui ont commis
ces actes une enquête a été ouverte et
certains éléments permettent de penser
que les personnes pourraient être
retrouvés rapidement gérald darmanin
s'est rendu sur place ce jeudi matin le
ministre de l'intérieur a promis une
enveloppe de 4 millions d'euros pour la
sécurisation des lieux de cultes en
france notamment pour financer des
moyens de vidéoprotection je suis venu
d'abord dire à la commune de romainville
commune bondy tout mon soutien dire
aussi aux catholiques bien sûr ici de
seine saint denis mais de france entière
que que nous les soutenons que nous
sommes outragé également lorsqu'on vient
toucher un lieu de culte et le
fonctionnement du culte et en tant que
ministre des cultes mon travail c'est de
les protéger
un acte salué par l'église catholique
reste à savoir dans quelle disposition
cet argent sera distribué